elle pour évoquer le sujet avec nous au
john locke lang spécialiste des
relations internationales et
universitaires britanniques bienvenu
merci d'être avec nous alors on en est à
la phase de négociation commerciale qui
est en position de force
selon ussel je dirais londres plus tôt
d'abord parce que boris johnson est en
position de force politique
il vient de gagner tout le monde le sait
des élections législatives avec une
majorité de 80 sièges à la chambre des
communes une majorité de 85 sièges ça ne
se perd pas en une élection il est très
difficile de renverser ce genre de
majorité lors d'une élection législative
c'est à dire que boris johnson sera
premier ministre pour dix ans non pas
seulement pour cinq ans mais pour dix
ans au moins en position de force aussi
parce que boris johnson dans le discours
qu'il a prononcé aujourd'hui essais et
je pense qu'il va réussir de m la
commission européenne et l'union
européenne en général devant ses propres
contradictions
quelles sont-elles ces contradictions et
bien elles vont je dirai au coeur du
problème qui sépare le royaume uni de
l'union européenne l'union européenne
tout le monde le sait est basé sur le
concept a marché un marché unique mais
en réalité ce marché est un prétexte
pour construire un ordre juridique alors
que justement ce que les britanniques
veulent et cela depuis 47 ans c'est un
marché et le commerce mais sans un ordre
juridique et le commissaire barnier et
les autres peuvent très bien répété qu'
il n'y aura pas d'accès au marché unique
européen
sans un alignement sur les normes
européennes mais en même temps ces mêmes
commissaires vont un peu partout dans le
monde en chine
pardon pas encore en chine au japon au
vietnam au canada en australie où il
s'empresse à signer des accords de libre
échange avec quasiment le monde entier
ils voulaient ans signé avec les états
unis
donc vous voyez la contradiction d'une
part il parle libre échange
mondiale et d'autre part ils disent ah
non attention notre marché unique on ne
peut pas y accéder sans s'aligner sur
les normes ce que c'est que bien sûr les
autres pays tiers ne font absolument pas
de jacques bordé svensson justement
indiqué qu'il voulait un accord de libre
échange similaire avec celui conclu
entre l'union européenne et le canada
exactement mais mais la contradiction
nous l'avons nous avons entendu pas
renié dire là tout d'abord que l'union
européenne signe bien volontiers des
accords avec des pays tiers mais
pourquoi pas donc avec le royaume uni
parce que ce marché unique tant vanté
par la commission européenne est en fête
est en réalité un prétexte pour une
union politique
angela merkel par les deux concurrents
pour qualifier londres après le
président est ce que aujourd'hui vu que
le break site est actée est-ce que
londres va devenir un concurrent de
l'union européenne oui mais un
concurrent loyal enfin oui mais oui je
crois il faut le dire je pense que il le
faut il faut appeler un chat un chat
le divorce est un événement majeur le
précité d'un événement majeur et je
pense que l'on peut dire que les deux
vont désormais être des concurrents car
justement le but du break site le but
large du bric side c'est pour que le
royaume uni puisse se séparer de cette
zone de non croissance et de faiblesse
économique qui est l'union européenne et
d'effectuer un pivot vers les zones de
grande croissance dans le monde qui sont
l'asie surtout la chine mais l'asie en
général et bien sûr les états unis
suffit de regarder les chiffres pour
comprendre que ces zones là ont une
croissance beaucoup plus vigoureuse que
celle de l'union européenne
donc oui je pense que le royaume uni va
être un concurrent le conquérant que
partenaire privilégié londres et
bruxelles
je pense que le royaume uni va être un
concurrent parce que justement il
voudrait prouver que
il est possible pour un état européen
d'avoir ses propres lois d'avoir ses
propres son propre ordre juridique de ne
pas dépendre de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne et encaisse que sont
donc de briser le mythe de l'union
européenne donc oui je pense que c'est
un piège au camp qui dit concurrents ne
dit pas ennemis et bien évidemment on
est deux côtés vont essayer de dire
combien ils sont partenaires puisqu'ils
vont rester évidemment partenaires sur
le plan militaire et cetera mais mais
mais oui je pense qu'il faut il ne faut
pas occulter la réalité qui est que le
royaume uni tourner le dos maintenant au
projet européen et de façon décisive
très rapidement on a pu beaucoup de
temps est ce que ça vous paraît
suffisant pour négocier un accord
commercial entre mandret et bruce
si on dit que ça ne durera pas plus
qu'annoncé ce qu'ils ont merci beaucoup
monsieur le plan d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle que vous êtes universitaires
britanniques merci